many other prominent leftists vowed to
leave the platform though most of them
appear to still be on the platform as of
this morning i mean
uh some of these a lot of these people
have been tweeting over and over and
over again about how they're not going
to use the platform anymore
and yet they're still using it to talk
about how they're not going to use it
perhaps their accounts merely identify
as deactivated i don't know another
common complaint has been that elon musk
is spending his money on buying twitter
when he could be using it to end world
hunger you know because world hunger is
all his fault john fuglesang tweeted for
44 billion dollars a guy could have gone
down in history for ending world hunger
history will record that our mega
billionaires had other priorities
now funny i don't remember those kinds
of criticisms when jeff bezos used his
money to buy the washington post
but the criticisms
would have been stupid in that case also
because in fact
even the richest men in the world don't
have enough money to end world hunger
there is no amount of money that could
wipe out world hunger i if i had 10
trillion dollars
to dedicate to wiping out world hunger
there would still be world hunger even
after the 10 trillion is spent or rather
wasted
because a lot of the hunger in the world
is due not to a simple lack of resources
but to corrupt and incompetent
governments and regimes throwing money
at that problem isn't going to solve it
in fact many times it could make it a
lot worse
as we have seen time and time and time
again
meanwhile groups like human rights watch
and the aclu are raising different
concerns they're issuing dire warnings
about the epidemic of hate speech that
may now be coming for us
and coming to twitter because of elon
musk
these worries were echoed all over cable
news especially by brian stelter listen
to this
if you
uh
if you get invited to something where
there are no rules where there is total
freedom forever everybody do you
actually want to go to that party or are
you going to decide to stay home and
that's a question for twitter users some
twitter users might love the idea
there's going to be absolutely no
moderation and no rules at all others
might not want to be anywhere near that
am i am i crazy matt no no you're right
and what what happens to the advertising
i mean if there's no moderation or
little moderation do the advertisers
stay away what does that do to the
business prospects for twitter itself
there's just something perfect about
this because i can totally imagine brian
stelter standing outside of a party and
saying excuse me i need to know the
ground rules for this party before i
come in
do you have the rules posted anywhere
i want to make sure everyone is
following the rules
this isn't one of those parties without
rules is it
and then everybody inside the party will
just look at him and say uh you weren't
invited brian
what are you doing here
stop hiding in the bushes you're weirdo
go home
of course minor detail here stelter is
lying obviously musk has never said that
there will be no moderation at all i
mean that's that's the thing about all
this this panicking oh he's gonna get
rid of the rules he actually never said
he was gonna do that
but it is fascinating to see the
evolution the left has gone from the
counterculture
to the hall monitors pushing up their
glasses and you know prattling on about
the rules
the left you know they're now the kid in
your class who reminds the teacher to
give out the homework assignment
they're that kid
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated